let's try to get our brains back in the
right spot from this morning lots us
happened between then and now I rewrote
up what we started with this morning do
you remember this is the very first one
we had a look at if you don't remember
because you want a slightly comatose
state that's all right that's why I'm
reviewing it we decided that we would
prove this do you remember what we did
we took this guy here this is the k plus
k plus one statement okay what did we do
to this and then start working on a real
you you to subtraction right why did I
subtract the thing I subtract was this
why do I subtract that from both sides
what was the point
yeah if I can get the right-hand side to
be zero this is much easier to work with
I'm like oh just prove that a thing is
positive and you know it still work but
at least I've got like machinery in my
brain that can handle that right girls
hurry up please now that was just one of
the methods do you remember I asked you
to write it down so hopefully you have
it there in your piece of paper I
suggested there was also another
technique that you can use which doesn't
involve starting here it involves
starting somewhere else have you got it
on your paper what does it say begin
from the assumption that's this guy here
okay so as Jacob so enthusiastically
read out we're going to begin right away
by just writing down two to the K is
greater than K so k squared 2 to the K
is greater than K squared we're gonna
say this is by assumption and now this
is what we got to work on okay now the
reason why I showed you the other method
before is because I think it's slightly
easier you'll probably get to the end of
this and think oh why do we have this
extra method I will explain that but
let's think about what we can do with
this okay here's my standing point where
I want to end my final line should be
this that's where I'm trying to head
okay so can someone suggest to me what
might be the easiest thing I can do to
start myself on the road to get from
this to make it look something like that
any suggestions what are your name
multiplying both sides my to be a great
idea because from out next laws right we
know that multiplying this by two puts
that K plus one at the top that's good
and then we've got the left-hand side
sort of dime and I can forget about it
that's really nice can we go ahead and
do that right I'm gonna multiply the
left-hand side by two so I'm also gonna
multiply the right-hand side by two okay
now you've got two K squared there and
have a look as with all induction proofs
not just cine qualities you should
always have one eye on your working and
then one eye on your destination where
are you headed where are you trying to
get to this is where you're trying to
get to okay have a look at how many K
Squared's will be in there once I expand
it out how many just the one right and
I've got like a spare here right so
here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna break
this apart into well here's the one that
I want and then I've got like some extra
stuff right now I don't want this
actually to be K squared I wanted to
factorize and look like this so now I'm
gonna think about this guy I'm gonna
think about it just like I did before
in light of the fact that K is not just
any number it has to be a number bigger
than 4 so far so good so let's write
this if K is bigger than 4 what can I
say about it in relation to K squared
ever think what could I do to this to
make it look more like that I could
swear it I could square both sides that
would be fine some of them might be more
helpful and you'll see why hopefully in
a minute is instead of just squaring
both sides I'm gonna multiply both sides
by K all right so if I do that K squared
is bigger than 4 K by the way why can I
multiply by K we've seen before you
can't do everything to inequalities you
do with equations but this is fine why
can I multiply by K and everything's
alright thank you Ches Ches positive
it's the integer but it's got to be
bigger than 0 right so it doesn't break
my inequality here right let's use that
trick that we did before to remember as
we go further down because the left-hand
side this guy is bigger than this I can
keep on making the right-hand side
smaller and smaller and smaller and
everything is still okay yeah so if K
squared is bigger than 4 K I'm gonna
swap that K squared first
being smaller okay are you following the
logic so far this is Mike like my 100
and this is my 1450 99 that's what I was
doing right they're all the same so I've
got something bigger something smaller
the inequality is still all right this
is closer so this how many K's will
there be in this thing once it's
expanded two of them right I'm gonna
need this side of the board you want two
of them I better write the left-hand
side so it's not just hanging out in the
middle you want two K's but I've got
four of them actually so I'm gonna say
well he's the two that I want and then
I've got a couple spare right can you
see where I'm going here I'm going to
use that spare bit at the end and refer
back to what I said before K is not just
any number it's bigger than four okay is
bigger than four so if that's bigger
than four what can I say about 2k think
about what I can do it's gonna be bigger
than eight right I'm just multiplying
both sides by two
yes so I'm gonna keep on going I'm
substituting bits and pieces and making
it smaller and smaller and everything is
still preserved K squared plus 2k plus 8
that thing's a little bit smaller right
do you see where I'm going I'm always
there right what do I actually want at
the end I want a one don't I well I have
a one it's just hiding inside the 8 I
say oh I've got the 2k and I've got the
1 and then I have some spare stuff right
but that's fine because there are
qualities I can just kind of discard the
things that I don't mean see this is k
plus 1 all squared that's the
factorization right if you're bigger
than that I'm gonna substitute that 7
for something smaller namely 0 and I can
say BAM I am there ok now if you have a
look at the lines like if you actually
counted the lines this might be slightly
longer than our previous method this
might be more confusing to you like wow
I have to do this thing over and over
again there's more changing of the
inequality which you might feel
uncomfortable with but it's another tool
in your toolbox right that's why I put
this picture up here the whole point of
giving you two methods is that what
mathematician does
to say well just because the first
method that I try isn't working what
makes you mathematicians you just try
something else
and if that's in work you just try
another thing you don't just walk away
and give up okay